Speaker 1: All right, some of you are going
to be mad at me for covering this story, but
I would be a Partizan hypocrite if I didn't
cover this story. Except the other half of
you are going to be mad at me for covering
this story the way that I'm going to cover
it. There is a video floating around in which
the story goes. Joe Biden appears very, very
visibly confused at a speech last week where
after speaking, he turned and he tried to
shake hands with thin air and then looked
so confused on the stage and didn't know where
to go when he has dementia and he has Alzheimer's,
and it's worse than Trump and all of this
different stuff. And I'll tell you when over
the weekend the clip was sent to me and I
looked at it on my small phone screen. Very
quickly, it looked very bad. Joe Biden looked
confused. It looked like he was shaking hands
with the air, thinking there was someone standing
next to him and there was no one there and
I was getting ready to come to you and say,
Guys, I mean, listen, we have a dozen examples
of Trump with this type of stuff. I've got
to tell you that we have one with Joe Biden,
except then I actually looked at the video
that was not cropped into a sort of vertical
video where you actually see the sides of
what's going on and it actually is fine. Joe
Biden is very clearly speaking to people on
different sides of him and signaling to them
with his hand. Yes, it looks weird. He's sticking
it out almost like a handshake, but he points
to the people to the right, and he turns around
and he points to the people that were over
his left shoulder and over his right shoulder.
And that's just kind of it, is it? We're going
to look at it. And once I saw the full video,
it really just kind of seems like no big deal.
So I'm going to play it for you. And I know
that if you're only listening, you're not
really going to get the full picture of this.
But let's take a look at it and then I'll
explain it, and we'll go from there.
Speaker 2: America can't do what we do it
together as the United States of America.
God bless you.
Speaker 1: So I mean, listen, I I was ready
to say something's wrong with Joe Biden, we
got to evaluate Joe Biden. But when you actually
look at what he's doing, he he's engaging
with each wing of the crowd and he's saying
something. I don't know if it's like, how
was it or. Thanks for being here. But he's
very clearly turning to the people on his
right and he says something. And then he turns
and faces back and he does the exact same
thing. You see his arm do the exact. So I
don't want to belabor this, but it's not what
it initially appeared to be that that's just
kind of it. And I would tell you guys, when
Trump looked confused and lost right when
Trump got off of his plane and his limo, his
car's right in front of him and he seems to
wander off and literally a Secret Service
agent comes over and takes him by the arm
and turns him around and walks him back toward
his car. He seemed very confused, and there
was no real simple explanation for that. When
Donald Trump said he wanted to know the fringes
of an investigation and he kind of like glitches,
and he knows that what's coming out of his
mouth doesn't make sense. He wants to say
origins, and he's saying oranges. And he tries
again, and it doesn't. That was really weird.
There's been no real explanation for that.
Not even a simple one. When Rudy Giuliani
was sitting right across from Trump at a table
and Trump says, Where is Rudy? And he's looking
around, and Rudy's as close as, you know,
not as close as my microphone, but right across
the table. There was no explanation for that,
and I told you that. And when Joe Biden has
completely lost his train of thought, I've
told you that really doesn't look good. That's
not his stutter. Joe Biden has had a lifelong
stutter when he completely loses his train
of thought. The end says, well, OK, let me
move on because they don't want me talking
about this. It just seems like he's losing
his train of thought, and I've told you guys
this video is not what many are making it
out to be. What what I I don't I don't even
know what else to say. Does Biden sometimes
sound confused? Yeah, he does. And I don't
like when it happens. It makes me uncomfortable.
Does sometimes. Does Joe Biden sometimes lose
his train of thought? Yeah, absolutely. But
this video as the smoking gun dementia VIDEO
I just don't see it, guys. If you disagree
with me, I want you to let me know